-Our first guest tonight is
a talented actress
you know from "The Newsroom"
and "The Daily Show."
She stars in "Violet," which is
in select theaters Friday,
and at home on demand
November 9th.
Let's take a look.
-All the benefits of knowing
someone for 20 years, I guess.
-You're a baby.
-Mm-hmm.
-You know,
I-I feel weird lately.
-Don't tell her.
-Are you sick?
-No, I just -- You know,
the committee in my head.
You know, I just never really
noticed it much before.
-What committee?
-You know, the voice that
tells you that
you're a piece of [bleep]
you know, or whatever.
I mean, everybody has it.
You know what I'm talking about.
-I guess.
-You sound crazy.
-Please welcome back to the show
Olivia Munn!
How are you, Olivia?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey. How are you, Seth?
-It's always great to see you.
And I want to start off
by saying congratulations.
I know you're expecting a baby.
How's it going?
-Thanks.
Yeah, it's going really good.
It's -- it's --
I'm exhausted a lot, I'm tired,
but it's going really good.
I'm getting lots of really
great advice from people
and lot of confusing advice,
as well,
but I'm doing really good.
-Do you find -- I found one
of the most confusing things is,
people would suggest
specific baby gear to you
that was important to have.
And the brand names
were impossible
to keep separate in my head.
-That's 100% true.
I mean, there's this
one item called the SNOO
that people bring up a lot.
And then, I'm not --
And I'm not quite sure --
Like, I know it's one
that rocks the baby.
Then there's, like,
one that docks the baby.
And then there's another
one that, like, props the baby.
And they're all, like --
You're right.
They're all named
the same thing,
and I have no idea
what anyone's --
I mean,
I'm trying to research it.
I actually have the --
The thing I have
the hardest problem with is,
I don't know
how many things to get.
You know, like, I don't know
how many onesies
you're supposed to get.
I don't know how many bottles
you're supposed to get,
how many diapers
you're supposed to have.
Like, I don't --
People give me a lot of advice,
but I need real specific --
-I think you only need
one onesie.
I think that's why
they're called that.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's right
in the name for you.
Have you received anything
that you would --
I mean, I know it's impossible
until you actually
have the baby,
but is there something that
you feel like
has been good advice?
-Yeah, there's so much
great advice.
But I honestly --
The one piece of advice
that's coming to my head that I
would not classify as great,
but it's the only one
I'm thinking of right now is,
I have a friend of mine
who said she has a gift
of being able to tell you
how tall your baby will be.
And, yeah, so, I said --
She said,
"Do you want to know
how tall your baby will be?"
So, I said "Sure."
She said "Okay."
How tall are you?"
I said, "I'm 5'5"."
"She goes, "Okay.
How tall is John?"
I said, "He's 6 feet."
She goes "Hmm.
The baby will be 6 feet tall."
Like, I was like --
I don't know where
she comes up with those figures,
but, like, that's been, like --
I get that kind of advice
from people.
-Maybe you need, like --
I don't know --
like, friends with, like, a
firmer background in child-care.
I do love anybody who's like,
"I'm going to make a prediction"
where you can't find out
if they're right or wrong
until, like, the kid's 18.
-I know. I know.
-"Promise I'm right.
Stay in touch."
-Unless she's talking about
a 6-foot baby
that comes out of me.
It just stretches.
It just keeps going.
-I love talking to you
about your mom.
Is she excited about the fact --
I guess this is
the second time she's
going to be a grandmother?
-Yeah, you're right.
She is so excited.
And she said to me
the other day -- She said,
"Hey, I want to have the baby
for two weeks, 15 days."
And I said, "Yeah, you can come
visit whenever you want."
She goes, "No, no.
I want to have the baby all by
myself for two weeks, 15 days."
And I said, "You can come
and have all the time you want
by yourself with the baby."
And she said, "No.
I want to bring the baby
to Oklahoma, at my house,
all by myself for
two weeks, 15 days."
And I said, "Why do you want the
baby in Oklahoma, at your house,
by yourself
for two weeks, 15 days?"
And she said, "Because I want to
be able to do whatever I want
with the baby, and the parents
can't tell me no."
I'm like, "Okay, so,
I'll just give you my baby,
and you can do
whatever you want."
So she's not going to get
the baby for two weeks --
-Yeah. She gave away way too
much of the game in the ask.
I also like that --
I like that, in her head,
she thinks she needs two weeks,
"But just in case
it's not enough,
I might need that 15th day."
-Yeah, she needs a travel day
she's added in.
-You've got to be careful.
Like, I feel like
when grandparents
take their grandkids out, like,
they act like
they have diplomatic immunity
and no rules apply to them.
And, like,
they'll bring back the kids,
and the kids
will be all amped up.
And you're like,
"What'd you do?"
And they're like, "Nothing.
They had, like,
a coffee and some beef jerky."
You're like, "No."
-I remember when my --
we had my niece
when she was a baby,
and my sister had
really strict instructions like,
"I don't want her to have --"
Like, she had,
like, maybe a dairy allergy,
so she was like,
"I don't want her
to have this or any sugar yet."
And then I saw my mom
hand her an ice-cream cone,
and she goes, "Shh!
Don't tell the mom."
I was like, "This is crazy.
Like, you're --
What are you doing?
Like, the mom
should make the rules."
And, so, now I remembered that,
so, clearly, I'm like --
very like --
I'm very wary of her.
-I think that's
a very good place to be.
So, this film,
as we tell from the clip --
or hopefully people
could tell from the clip --
you play a woman, Violet,
in this film,
who is competing
with the voice in her head,
this sort of --
the voice that maybe anxiety
would put there for us.
And a pretty incredible actor
playing the voice.
-Yeah, that's Justin Theroux
playing that insidious voice
in my head, constantly,
you know, telling me --
telling Violet how
not good enough she is
and how, you know,
just everything is going to
burn to the ground
because of her.
-Was this part emotionally
exhausting to play,
to play somebody who's dealing
with these sort of
internal anxieties?
-This project was really
emotionally exhausting for me.
I had actually gone from
two independent movies
right into this
third independent movie
back-to-back-to-back.
So I was already so
emotionally exhausted,
physically exhausted.
And, I mean,
I am one of those people
that struggles with
that internal dialogue.
That's that voice that's always
telling me, you know,
so many things that just create
so much self-doubt
and self-hate.
I mean,
I struggle with that a lot.
And I've worked really hard to
put that voice into a box,
and so then,
to go on to this film
and be doing this role
with this voice --
And then there's
Justine Bateman,
who directed the film, and
she's yelling on the microphone,
you know, like, just screaming
out all these things to you.
It was really
emotionally draining
and it was so exhausting,
and there was times
that I just broke down crying
in the middle of a scene,
in the scenes where you're not
supposed to be crying,
but it's okay if I cried.
And I'm crying,
I'm breaking down crying,
and then they yell "cut,"
and I'm still crying.
And I'm just kind of trying to
remove myself to collect myself,
and then the A.D. comes over.
And they're like -- 'Cause it's
an independent movie,
so time is of the essence,
and there's no money.
He's like, "Hey, um, really need
you to, like, stop crying
and just get back to the scene."
And I was like, "Oh, okay."
Just trying to, like, reckon --
It was just like,
just bury it deep down,
like my mom taught me.
Just bury all that stuff and
just keep on going.
-See? That's what
she can teach your baby
when she has her
for two weeks, 15 days.
Just bury your emotions.
Hey, thanks so much
for being here, Olivia.
Congratulations on the baby.
Congratulations on the movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll see you soon.
-Thank you.
-Olivia Munn, everybody.
"Violet" is in
select theaters Friday
and at home on demand
November 9th.